this horrendous abuse of power is the
latest in a long series of witch hunts
we started a long time ago I thought as
Donald Trump eyes up a return to the
White House he's found himself in a New
York courthouse the first former
president in American history to face
criminal charges what's the breaking
news coming into us here at Sky News the
grand jury in New York has voted to
indict former president Donald Trump on
a felony charge Donald Trump is facing
numerous investigations not least
allegations he incited the storming of
Congress on January the 6th back in 2021
oh
I was on Capitol Hill that day as those
violent scenes unfolded there were
scenes that shocked the world
but it's not the January the sixth Riot
that's landed Donald Trump in court nor
the classified documents found at
Mar-A-Lago or any of the other stuff
it's about a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars hush Money Paid to the porn star
Stormy Daniels to keep her quiet about a
sexual liaison she claims they had in
2006. he has never thought that the
little man or especially women and even
more women like me mattered that ends
now the money was paid by Donald Trump's
lawyer at the Time Michael Cohen I am
ashamed that I chose to take part in
concealing Mr Trump's illicit acts but
it's how the former president officially
recorded his reimbursement this being
investigated
prosecutors say he falsified business
records
so could this legal Showdown wind the
former president up in jail or could it
actually win him support for his bid to
run again in 2024. either way America is
in Uncharted water
I'm Sally Lockwood and this is the Sky
News Daily
we're recording this podcast before
details of the charges are revealed to
the public so check the Sky News app for
more on that when those drop but in the
meantime we're going to discuss the
bigger picture the mood among
Republicans and why Donald Trump has
seen a bouncing support since he was
indicted
first let's unravel what these charges
mean for Donald Trump yeah it's huge
isn't it and if there was any doubt
about that you just have to look look
around you James Matthews is our us
correspondent
I'm sitting in New York you look at the
TV
um endless panels of legal experts
political Experts squillions of
viewpoints pouring out around uh
something that's we've never seen before
a former president uh being indicted
charged given the the common criminal
treatment when he is ushered in to this
this very austere soviet-style building
in lower Manhattan the Bowery area which
was the original skid role in New York
you know it's harder to see how much
further a former president could fall
but that is what confronts Donald Trump
is a man who faces legal Jeopardy on a
number of fronts it was the case many
thought was the weakest and the the
least likely to nail him but it's the
first in the queue and it relates to of
course this one night stand he had with
a former porn star Stormy Daniels hush
money the putting through the books of
that particular payment that was seen as
falsification of Records that's how the
prosecutors see it and they also think
there was a breach of campaigns Finance
law technically he's staring down the
barrel of four years in jail although
that's probably not likely because he's
a first-time non-violent offender but
you know in the political legal context
unprecedented historic and huge
attention around that courthouse in New
York
now James his former lawyer Michael
Cohen was jailed several years ago for
his involvement in these hush money
payments to Stormy Daniels explain to us
why it's taken so long for Donald Trump
to be indicted over this the reason this
took us along Sally is frankly he was in
power there is a justice department
policy that a sitting president doesn't
get indicted then really the the delays
were a matter of process just working
through the evidence and building a case
covert didn't help that caused the delay
in the various investigations into
Donald Trump and there have been many of
them it's just that this particular case
has risen to the top uh after you know
wide-ranging investigations
um corn is interesting yes he has served
time in jail he was the the fixer he was
Trump's Mr Fixit the man who went to
Stormy Daniels when there was a fear in
the Trump Camp just before the 2016
election that she was going to tell her
story so he gave you you know he went to
her said look we don't want you going
public with that story it could it could
be damaging for Donald Trump uh we want
to give you money she said Grand well in
actual fact she said 130 Grand that's
how much she was paid for her silence
they went after Michael Cohen he has
done jail time during his trial he
pointed the finger at Donald Trump he
said look okay I paid the money but it
was Trump who directed me and that is
where we are at the moment there's a
credibility issue with Michael Cohen
apart from anything else he is a
convicted felon if anyone knows where
Donald Trump's skeletons are James
certainly it will be Michael Cohen and
and certainly we understand that he's
already met with Alvin Bragg the
Manhattan district attorney a number of
times explain why Alvin Bragg is being
so widely discussed in this story as
well because he's the man who will
prosecute Donald Trump he's Chief
prosecutor district attorney in lower
Manhattan and as such he is the the
target for Donald Trump's vitriol the
Trump Playbook is attack attack and also
try to delay legal proceedings against
them we've seen that time and again and
Alvin Bragg is the man at the center of
all of this is his Target in Chief and
it's caused difficulties
um you know we've got Donald Trump
uh on his social media platform and
elsewhere
uh calling Alvin Bragg an animal a woke
Tyrant Alvin Bragg has received death
threats there was quite powder sent to
uh the core building that he works from
he comes and goes from that building and
uh Lower Manhattan with tight security
and you know we see the Trump strategy
that we've seen time and again
conflating a media strategy frankly with
a legal fight his lawyers are all across
the American Media putting scorn on this
he's got his Republican colleagues
calling it a political Witch Hunt
calling it a weaponization of the
justice system and you know it appears
to work for him certainly in the
immediate term it stirs the Trump base
look at his fundraising since his arrest
he's raised five million dollars in
funds
this case on the when you look at the
division and the arguments around it and
that the noise is off it is a stress
test for for this country's institutions
legal and political will proper Justice
be seen to be served will this be seen
to be politically biased will due
process through the courts be something
that can be influenced by the pr
campaigns that poor scorn around it
there will be all sorts of arguments
around the rule of law in this country
arising from this and they're being
current they're being encouraged don't
forget by Donald Trump himself and his
incendiary comments calling for people
to protest calling for people to take
our nation back
and
you know this won't end anytime soon I
was on Capitol Hill uh on January the
6th during that huge protest Riot
Insurrection whatever you want to call
it James and for a lot of people they're
surprised that it that it's Stormy
Daniels that's done it for Donald Trump
what's been the reaction in America to
that it has somewhat come out of the
blue because all the headlines around
Donald Trump have been around the other
cases the other potential prosecutions
that he is facing around Georgia where
he allegedly was involved in an attempt
to overturn the result in that state of
the 2020 election there is a mishandling
or alleged mishandling of classified
documents at his Mar-A-Lago home in
Florida there is also his involvement
around the January the 6th Insurrection
you know big federal crimes crimes
related to overturning
the government of the country subverting
democracy so he is staring down the
Battle of these other
certainly significant cases arguably
more important and the Stormy Daniels
singers rather come up on the inside it
wasn't the the hot favorite for the
biggest and possibly the first
prosecution that Trump faces but it is
the weakest and I think generally there
would be a view that if they can nail
him on this one then the rest will
follow on pretty easily if in a New York
Court
they can break him here
they can break him anywhere
let's now turn our attention to the mood
among those in the Republican party at
the moment following this news of Donald
Trump's indictment it's
different time but
it's been extremely divided so you have
one side that is cheering and very
excited about the indictment and on the
other side you have disappointment the
sadness and disgust quite honestly with
our justice system Amy tokanyen is a
Republican strategist and former chair
of the Nevada Republican party it will
just be very interesting to see what the
outcome will be I don't anticipate there
to be any violence
um but I do anticipate there to be a
Groundswell of support for president
Trump I think this is going to catapult
president Trump into the nomination
unfortunately and I say that
um being a prior supporter of the
presidents I was a delegate and I also
voted for him twice but I do think that
this nation is tired they are exhausted
of everything that surrounds this
President as far as chaos and the circus
um that is constantly going on uh you
know surrounding him and so you know I
know that people are also tired of
President Biden I think that the nation
is ready for fresh faces and um but I
think once again this is going to help
president Donald Trump and it's only
going to further embolden his base some
Americans I've spoken to a surprise that
it's been a payment and to Stormy
Daniels that has seen Donald Trump be
criminally charged what's your take on
that it looks politically motivated it
smells politically motivated Let's Take
January 6 for example you know once that
investigation is found you know now
you're going to have a good part of the
nation kind of blow it off and say you
know yes president Trump I agree with
you that it is in fact a Witch Hunt and
they're not going to take the justice
system seriously it's a sad day for
America you don't have to support Donald
Trump to see that this is not going in
the right direction
[Music]
do you think Donald Trump is worried
he's going to end up in jail I think
he's probably worried whether he'll be
president uh more than going to jail but
I this is a very weak case Sarah Elliott
is spokesperson for the political
organization Republicans overseas UK
she too thinks the indictment is
politically motivated it seems like
they're trying to find the needle in the
haystack to finally pin Trump down and
put them in jail but it's motivated by
animosity and uh probably feel a bit
threatened by his candidacy as well
America is I think very much over the
Trump years very much really want to
move on they want to see America in a
better place they're not happy with Joe
Biden either uh you know he is failing
as a candidate uh he's clearly too old
for the job and uh there's really a very
short bent of candidates for the
Democrats and so what a better way than
to bring up the Democrats favorite enemy
arch nemesis and Boogeyman but Donald J
Trump and uh make Republicans look like
he's still the head of the party yeah
it's interesting isn't it the picture
that you paint the Democrats bringing up
their favorite enemy Donald Trump
because it actually has the opposite
effect when it comes to the impact that
that has on Republicans you know the
Maga movement uh adore Donald Trump and
this will only Galvanize their support
absolutely and it has he's raised five
million dollars in 48 hours a quarter of
which are from new donors
um this puts a lot of people who may not
have voted for or may not have uh
support him now for 2024 supported him
in 2020 but it kind of ready to move on
but maybe it makes them rethink and go
you know what this guy has been
um really bullied and harassed and it's
been unfair and unjust and he needs to
now win and just really show it to the
Democrats and so this may be
um a turning point where he gets more
support that may have left him over
January 6. this might encourage him I
mean his poll numbers have doubled also
in the last couple days I'm not sure it
lasts I'm not sure his lead continues as
the campaign picks up steam back to Amy
now on just how this is playing out in
the polls with American voters and
whether this indictment could help or
hinder Donald Trump's Ambitions to
return to the White House oh it's going
to help him in fact if they do decide to
release the mug shot because in New York
they do not regularly release the mug
shots but if for some reason that is
released that will be his campaign
poster that will be on every campaign
t-shirt sweatshirt email blast and it
will end up catapulting him into the
nomination
in effect this could end up backfiring
on on the left as you see it it makes
Donald Trump a martyr that the swamp is
after him massively because in a primary
you have the party devoted that pay
closer attention your average voter is
more concerned about getting their
children to school putting food on the
table they don't pay attention to the
details of an election until it gets
closer to the general President Biden is
not this exceptional candidate either
and I know a number of those on the left
are hoping to find a replacement so you
know President Biden was lucky uh to
become president he's not somebody who
people were looking towards thinking
that this was the new Barack Obama of
Hope and change he happened to just be
in the right place at the right time and
people were exhausted it was a vote
against Trump
do you see Donald Trump being back in
the White House
I honestly hope not I would like to see
somebody new somebody who exudes
strength but has a better Persona
somebody who exudes you know more of a
Statesman or States woman but yet can
can still get the job done and put forth
the policies that our nation so
desperately needs
and back to Sarah now on how she thinks
this could all play out I can see Donald
Trump making the most of it and saying
look I have to go back to defend myself
in the Witch Hunt again you know here I
go wish me well and don't forget to help
my campaign and give 49 here I think he
will definitely live it up but will
Americans really want a president
who you know may go to jail uh do we
really want to get behind somebody with
you know who just attracts this level of
attention and scrutiny it definitely in
the eyes of Republicans elevates His
Image makes him more sympathetic and
they still see him as this pitbull in
the ring willing to fight for their
freedoms and their liberties
it's a long way until election day
especially in politics so I think it's
hard to predict
James a final thought from you if I may
you know we saw during Donald Trump's
time in office that the usual rules just
don't apply when it comes to Donald
Trump and many feel uh this indictment
the fact he now faces criminal charges
it could help him rather than hinder him
in terms of his political capital what's
your take on that
I think it will help him in the
immediate term I think we see evidence
of that from the fundraising and from
his performance in the opinion polls
actually you know for all the talk about
him being vulnerable to a challenge from
Rhonda Santos uh he's way out in front
of DeSantis and you know at all intents
and purposes he is looking like he will
be the Republican nominee his trouble
will be uh beyond the Republican
primaries in a presidential campaign
it's one thing being The Outsider the
man taking on the establishment we've
seen how that chimes with his core
support but he was deserted and has been
repeatedly at elections presidential and
midterms by The Independents the swing
voters the voters who took a chance on
him in 2016 but have since deserted him
you know I remember in the days when he
was buying golf courses in Scotland we
were interviewing him at Aberdeen
airport and it was the big sit down in
surrounded by you know his PR people big
Trump Team all clocking around him and
in the course of the interview we had a
young camera assistant with us and he
happened to close the door so there was
a slight clunk off camera which you know
nobody heard except Donald Trump you
know he decided to stop the interview
shouted at this youngster he guy he said
and it was all very awkward when you
looked at his you know his PR staff they
actually you saw fear that things were
not going right but when you looked at
Donald Trump
all I saw on his face was an enjoyment a
satisfaction he was The Man In Charge he
was a man in control of all around him
whether he knew them whether it was
strangers or not uh you know and I
thought to myself that day that's a man
who who needs control who feeds off it
right now uh he's not in control
he is pray to the events that are all
around him that threaten him threaten
his political future and me well lead
him towards a jail sentence
my thanks to James Amy and Sarah and to
you for listening to the Sky News Daily
with me Sally Lockwood this podcast was
produced by Annie Joyce the editor was
Paul stanworth and if you fancy more
episodes on Donald Trump have a scroll
back through our feed there's quite a
few to choose from